walid partage cette chambre exiguë avec
un autre migrant pakistanais comme lui
tous deux sont arrivés la semaine
dernière dans ce centre de demandeurs
d'asile près de saint florentin
ils ont fui la libye sur un bateau de
fortune ont été secourus en mer par
l'aquarius sont passés par malte avant
de se poser enfin ici dans l'yonne
c'était très dangereuse vraiment
dangereux parce qu'on à risquer notre
vie
et si jamais en vo tonné pakistan ont un
nom libye au petit perdre la ville
voilà pourquoi on a choisi de fuir
l'aquarius empêché d'accoster en italie
malte paris puis l'yonne comme walid
ils sont cinq en tout quatre pakistanais
et un ivoirien sauvé par le navire
humanitaire est aujourd'hui hébergé dans
ce centre
tous n'aspire qu'à retrouver un peu de
calme l'apd est plus que les autres en
effet il ya besoin de ce temps de répit
dans un premier temps où les personnes
peuvent prendre la température de leur
nouvel environnement sont reposés
prendre soin d'eux
et se débarrasser un peu des soucis
qu'ils ont connu durant leur exil walid
va bientôt entamer les démarches pour sa
demande d'asile est très vite aussi
prendre comme ici des cours de français
au sein du centre
pour l'heure il vite avec 4 euros par
jour dette de l'état il n'a pas le droit
de travailler et préparer un simple
repas suffit à son bonheur
très heureux est vraiment chanceux
d'être encore en vie d'avoir été
secourus en mer
beaucoup de migrants sont morts en
méditerranée à cause du mauvais temps ou
d'embarcations de fortune
lee devrait rester un an ou plus à
verger ni le temps de sa demande d'asile
à 19 ans il a laissé sa famille au
pakistan et espère démarrer une nouvelle
vie en france